[Music]
uh emergency emergency podcast
uh i had to do this saw this video the
other day
i was scrolling tick tock late into the
night
as i do
i saw this tick tock couldn't believe it
i almost got out of bed right then to
come record this
but we're doing it now okay this is the
one of the most ridiculous things i've
ever seen
this guy is going to be
skewered for this that's my prediction
this guy is going to he might get fired
for this uh but he is definitely gonna
get wrecked on all of social media for
this um
let's just let's listen to this so this
is the ceo of a company called
better.com they've raised like i don't
know 750 million dollars a big company
they do i don't know mortgages or some
[__] like that on the internet so uh
here's the ceo let's just let's just
take a listen
what's this take a listen
hi everyone um
thank you for joining um
already looks like a funeral
i come to you with not great news
um the market has changed as you know
and uh we have to move
with it
in order to survive so that hopefully we
can continue to thrive and okay
the market has moved
the market has moved what are you
talking about uh you have all your
employees on a zoom call right now
obviously you have some quote not great
news to share
lesson number one and by the way how
does this guy become a ceo of such a big
company and not know rule number one
if you're letting someone go or you're
laying them off and you go into the
meeting
you gotta rip the band-aid off in the
first minute
and the first
three things you say one of them has to
be
we're gonna be letting you go today
and then you start to explain everything
when you do this you do this long-winded
buildup
people are a confused and b they get
really pissed off and it's just
self-serving you're trying to buffer the
blow you're trying to prevent the the
blow from hitting you you can't even say
it you're not you're not even willing to
say it so uh ridiculous okay let's so
the market has moved and we have to move
with it so we can survive what is it is
you're shutting down the company what's
going on
deliver on a mission
a mission what mission this is the news
that you're going to want to hear
uh but ultimately it was
my decision
and
i wanted you to hear from me
looks at his notes dude you still
haven't said it it's been a really
really challenging decision to make um
are you okay are you has it been hard
for you
this is the second time in my career i'm
curious and i do not do not want to do
this
the last time i did it i cried
um this time i hope to be stronger
but we are late oh my god what are you
thinking dude i get what he's thinking
he's thinking
i want them to know that this is hard
for me
but dude you don't understand what
people are feeling right now they don't
first of all they don't know what you're
saying
you haven't said it
secondly
you're talking about how hard this is
for you
and the last time i cried no one gives a
flying [__] if you cried or not um
because you still haven't said it that's
also that's the main problem the second
problem is you're talking about yourself
and no one cares about you in this
moment
off
about 15
of the company
laying off their first races
the
you can hear a guy the guy who's okay
the guy who's recording this by the way
this is not the screen this is a guy
pointing his camera at the phone and you
heard him are you feeling serious
efficiency
and
performances
and productivity
[Laughter]
and peanut butter
market market performances
efficiency
and peanut butter
what is this guy doing first of all he
said we're laying off 15 of the company
he didn't say which 15 yet now everybody
is just thinking is it me is it not me
they have no idea because he hasn't
brought the sledgehammer yet and look
this is the scroll bar all right this
down here is where he should have said
it we're now over here we're almost at
intermission of the movie and uh you
know he still hasn't said it so i can't
believe what he just said why did he say
performances by the way he's talking
about the market has turned so
oh is it my performance or is it the
market
princess
and productivity
if you're on this call
you are
part of the unlucky group [__] you dude
i can't even help but laugh [__] you
dude that is
see that guy is saying what he's
supposed to say
in this moment
because of this [__] up
hype trailer teaser
strategy that the ceo took
if you're on this call
you are you're not a game show he thinks
he's jeff probst he thinks he's a game
show host
and he's setting up this cliffhanger
that actually is pushing them off the
cliff and then they're they're falling
down to their death so
he he comes in with you are one of the
unlucky bunch unlike i thought you said
it's performance is it performance or is
it unlucky or is it the market or is it
peanut butter which one is it we don't
know yet
your employment here is terminated
effective immediately are you [__]
kidding me
what does this mean for what's next
you're going to get an email from hr ask
hr better.com to your personal email
address at
and better.com benefits
we're all u.s employees we're providing
four weeks
of severance
also
you dressed up like a douchebag on this
day you award the douchebag uniform the
blue collared shirt with the dark blue
vest with the khakis that are a little
too tight right around the crotch with
the crotch facing the camera that is the
douchebag that is the douchebag armor
that you wore into this
and then you're reading it really slow
off your piece of paper
and you just have a bunch of people
enraged at you right now i think there's
like i don't know a thousand people in
this call or something like that this is
something crazy uh a lot of people 100
maybe hundreds of people on this call
insane
one month of full benefits and two
months of cobra for which we will pay
the premium so three months
total benefits if we um if you elect for
cobra
if you don't get a communication from
ask hr better.com before the end of the
day you can email ask hr better.com
if you don't get the email thank you for
using everything
individual contributions to better
i wish the news was different
i wish
we were
thriving
enthusiastically as we were at the
beginning of this year
thriving enthusiastically doesn't make
sense
uh you wish you were thriving of course
you wish you were thriving you didn't
lose your job ceo who mismanaged during
this time you didn't lose your job they
lost their job and you're talking about
you were crying last time but you
weren't crying this time and you
probably didn't even cry last time you
probably don't give a [__] to be honest
with you maybe you feel bad i actually i
take the back he feels bad
he feels bad he should feel bad
but he handled it bad
you can feel bad but you gotta handle it
good he felt bad and handled it bad
peanut butter that's not the case
and
i am sure you better finish strong
be more successful
where are you going what is this wedding
speech and you're drunk we i'm sure you
will leave us what is he saying more
fortunate
and you'll be more [__] here in your
next endeavor i wish you all the best of
luck
thank you for everything you've done for
better
thank you
looks looks aggressively staged right
did i do it can we end it
can i go to lunch
do we have my lunch
did someone get my lunch
and this guy this guy i gotta look this
up
better
ceo salary
this might be public
uh
let's see let's see let's see
i feel like this guy
so he laid off 900 people in that call
we're not going to pay for this paywall
by the way
what is the stealing part i didn't hear
this okay i don't know i don't know what
that's about that wasn't in the video
but uh yeah i feel like i read somewhere
in a tweet now this might be total
[__] uh
but i've read somewhere that this guy
you know whatever uh
something like 10 million dollars of
compensation last year but that honestly
he's a private company so i don't i
don't know what's going on
they have a spac
of course they have us back
of course they went public with us
that's back
let's see better
it's back
yeah raised 750 million dollars from
their stack backers
they already had 1.5 billion
from softbank
so this guy easily easily this guy is
this guy the founder michelle garg
is he the founder
he um
google google said what company laid off
900 employees answer better.com
uh i think this guy was the founder yeah
founder and ceo so this guy easily
this company's valued multiple billions
of dollars this guy is clearly
worth over 500 million dollars probably
go for more than a billion dollars
and uh he's talking about lunch and his
douchebag outfit all right bad terrible
way to do it uh there's